I just like that when when we all win
and and then Nick's like he didn't win
we're like what were you thinking 50
cutaways what were you thinking you
idiot over he doesn't even know what he
bet on I'm going to ask him for $200 and
then 4 hours later I'm going be like hey
man we need another
$200 that's
[Music]
my so gentlemen it is time for the JK
third annual Super Bowl bet oh
yes okay I said in the group yeah that I
probably should go for the 49ers cuz I'm
from California yeah so it's the 49ers
versus the Chiefs and the only
quarterback that I ever liked as a kid
was Joe Montana cuz we both say had the
same name of Joe yep that's pretty sick
and also I went to San Francisco a lot
because my family lived there and also
I'm a big supporter of the lgbtq
community nice very that was perfect so
yeah so that's your and I like panning
for gold okay so 49ers is my team okay
who's the underdog in this though so
currently the uh I believe it's the it's
the Chiefs still really they're the
underdog I think so H let me just looks
like you got to go
Chiefs was it was it was it I I just go
against whatever you guys do or do I
always bet the underdog you always bet
against the boys because you're all
right I'll bet against you guys yeah but
then also were like I like the underdog
and then we won that one time the first
time we won the second time I won second
time Joe won so to be honest though it
feels really good to be the only one
winning like you know how people go like
happiness is best shared with your
friends I actually think that it's
better when your friends are sad and
then you win then you can rub it in
their face that is pry o o I even like
football but I won yeah you won and then
I made you come drive to me to get the
ticket cuz I wasn't going to drive it to
you did not ride with the boys y so you
had to come get it from
me love that that's so pett I'm Petty
I'm Petty I told you I'm Petty I prove
it every [__] day I wake up I did and
I cashed out the ticket myself yeah how
much are we putting down for this one
we're trying to do $1,000 each what for
real that's hella funny how much was it
last time 100 crazy
bro we did 100 bucks each so what I
thought we were going to chase our
losses every time so every single time
it gets a little bit like real gamblers
like real gamblers that's real gamblers
[__] dude 10 years from now it'll for
sure be $1,000 might even be like three
years chase our losses that's a good
tactic okay okay so no didn't we didn't
we bet 125 it was like 130 bucks though
why odd number like that what happened I
don't remember it might it might have
been the odds like you have to bet 125
to win 100 yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
so right now the line is 4 so are you
guys going to be 49ers and I'll be the
Chiefs well we got to talk about it all
right 49 49ers is right now -2 so that
they're the favorite team right now okay
but the Chiefs have a Kelsey and the
Taylor Swift and a Taylor Swift by the
way everyone's so pissed about Taylor
Swift or whatever for what reason though
so wild first of all there's just so
much to be mad about like during when
you're watching a football game like how
about the [__] Burger King commercial
they play every 5 seconds with the guy
like Whopper Whopper Whopper Whopper
nobody's mad about that everyone's mad
about Taylor Swift they cuz they cut to
a girl who's just what is she doing
wrong she's just clapping they're just
mad that they have to look at her during
all the cutway it's a bunch of like you
know I'm a macho dude I don't need be
seeing Taylor Swift you know if I want
to do that I go to her concert and [__]
like
that chill the [__] out she's delightful
who who doesn't like Taylor Swift I'm
always looking
forward for the musicians the half
that's what I'm looking forward to see
like the halftime show that's what the
world wants they have they have Usher
right user that's Prett that's going to
be sick that's awesome next year they're
trying to get Taylor Swift by the way to
to ultimately dig in yeah they actually
are [__] they're in early negotiation
dude if they still cut away to her
clapping that'd be [__] funny during
her actual show How how Wild how Wild
would it be if they were no longer
together and she's doing the [__]
Super Bowl it's even better only if he's
at the Super Bowl yeah it will yeah are
you going to go to the Super Bowl it's
in Vegas I'm not going to the [__]
Super Bowl dude it's like four grand oh
my god really Jesus Christ yeah I'm in
crypto accumulation mode D I'm not
[__] trying to dump a lot of crypto
[__] for Walter probably will you think
he'll go to the Super Bowl no only if
it's at Chargers oh in La no Rams Rams
yeah Rams how sick if it was Taylor and
Kanye oh dude for halftime show that be
so
sick so yeah it really comes down to so
okay so let me tell you my story right
I'll be getting my [__] clock clean
gambling this year right I is that good
or bad bad oh it's bad okay you don't
want to get your clock clean okay what
does that mean you want your clock to be
dirty yeah what why does the how does
that eism work I have no idea yeah it
was like a boxing term right when they
clean your clock knocked outed it's like
yeah you're knocked out it's like
ringing your Rosie like the time gets
stopped because you're [__] down on
the floor yeah you're seeing Stars I
don't know why but yeah I've been
getting killed this year getting
absolutely murdered right so I got
murdered first week of the playoffs I
Sports bet this only in the playoffs you
bet against Patriots I bet against the
[__] Chiefs Chiefs oh got killed that
week next week bet against the Chiefs
got killed that week so here we are I
think I got to bet the
Chiefs or do I dble triple down just say
[__] trip down triple
down so because how much better would it
be if you won be so nice I would love it
but how painful would it be if you lost
on it okay the only thing is that you
know got learn your lesson also arguably
like isn't isn't Mahomes kind of like a
a generational player yes you know what
I mean it's like to bet on him is like
kind of a but they didn't score in the
second half why is he so special again
cuz he's super young and he has so many
rings already dude he is like a Phenom
he's already tracking better than Brady
cuz he's like only he's under 30 years
old and he he almost has three Super
Bowls already oh man and he's been to
more he's been to four Super Bowls wow
that's pretty insane like in the
audience or like just playing and stuff
just watching yeah playing he's a
generational talent for sure I mean he's
like he's been to two Super Bowls front
stage the other two he actually played
the game he was in the parking lot yeah
yeah tailgate party so on the one hand
if it was just like a bet I think it
would be a funner bet to bet on the
Chiefs just as a betting person however
uh from like the sentimentality of like
watching the ners like take [__]
Super Bowl I feel like just growing up
my dad watching also like Joe Montana
and stuff like that Jer rice and all the
homies in San Francisco that obviously
like bleed San Francisco you know it's
like it's also so funny to like kind of
watch them lose though it's true you
know what I mean plus Niners fans are
the [__] worst they're the worst
they're the worst I thought Raiders fans
I thought Raiders fans are the worst cuz
they'll stab you Raiders fans are
hilarious I see yeah I think they're
more hilarious so Niner fans are like
Karen's Raider fans will shoot you yeah
Niner fans are entitled as Ken yeah is
Gavin Nome a Niners fan you think oh
probably God damn or maybe he's a Rams
fan I don't want him to be happy no me
either I think the all the the most fun
that we can have doing this is is just
imagining whatever Joe's feeling during
the game so having him be Underdog is
always fun M it is fun cuz then he gets
to double gloat if he wins hey that
first game was so fun cuz I was like
we're going to [__] win we got it in
the back and I took a nap in the middle
of the game and I woke up and I was like
[__] we lost so we need him to be Chiefs
then right Chief I'm so sick of betting
against the Chiefs dude I'm getting
killed I'm going to lose my
house wasn't there recent like a leak
where they're saying like a uh some
journalist or some news anchor like
messed up and announced that they were
going to win no they announced the Super
Bowl like way before they knew who was
playing but they were like oh yeah in a
few weeks at the Super Bowl would it's
Chiefs versus 49ers they like how they
know that already yeah but it was like
way and they knew like chiefs were going
to win or something like that there was
a whole thing about it cuz the logo came
out and the logo had the colors for it
had it has um purple and red in it and
so everyone was saying they're see it's
predictive programming they're showing
you it's gonna be the Ravens versus the
Chiefs or you you know what I mean but
or Niners Raiders versus Ravens was ners
but like that didn't happen Ravens lost
so I guess I mean I bet on them to win
there are a lot of preparation that goes
into things that they don't know who the
finals are anyway how easy do you think
it is to fix a game these days well if
you have the refs in your pocket maybe
it is easier that's what the argument is
but I don't [__] know bro did you see
that one tackle that time a mafia there
was like a tackle that went viral
recently where the dude was like he
could have tackled momes but he just
went for the other guy and softly nuded
that yeah and they're just circling them
like hey you missed the
guy and they're like tell me it's not
fixed if you see this clip but that's
like hard that it's like when you see
like refs making bad calls in like
basketball and stuff that's when you oh
like that one female ref that gave a
technical because the Dude passed her
the ball did you see that yeah it was
like really recent the guy you know like
after uh they blew the whistle whatever
he just like handed her the ball like
this and then she called it a technical
because she said it was the way he did
it but the comments though are [__]
hilarious he was mad at the way he did
it like it felt aggressive but clearly
in the video like his tone of passing a
ball yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
wild yeah it's [__] it's bad ref
calling yeah I don't know about that one
you were mean to me when you handed it
over so [__]
you so what are we betting guys yeah
what are we doing I say we go 49ers I
say Joe goes Chiefs cuz it makes it more
fun that
way it's more funny for you because you
don't get to do what you want and Joe
doesn't get to do what he want today's
video is brought to you by DraftKings
looking for a super offer for Super Bowl
58 DraftKings Sportsbook has you covered
Woo new customers can bet on the big
game and turn five bucks into 200
instantly in bonus bets take a look at
these lines and odds and see where you
want to place your bets download the
DraftKings Sportsbook app now and use
code off the Record new customers can
bet five bucks and get 200 instantly in
bonus bets only on DraftKings Sportsbook
an official sports betting partner of
Super Bowl
58 with code off the Record the crown is
yours gambling problem call- 1800
Gambler or in West Virginia visit www.1
1800 gambler. net in New York call 8778
Hope n or text h o p n 467 369 in
Connecticut help is available aable for
problem gambling call 888878 9777 77 or
visit ccpg dog please play responsibly
on behalf of Boothill Casino and Resort
in Kansas 21 plus h varies by
jurisdiction void in Ontario bonus bets
expire 168 hours after issuance see
dk.com fo for eligibility and deposit
restrictions terms and responsible
gaming resources dude last year I just
tricked I tricked myself cuz I was like
okay it's going to be it was Eagles
Chiefs and last year I had such a bad
stretch of gambling at the end that I
was like oh man I was like okay I was
like I think the Chiefs are going to win
so I'm going to bet against myself I'll
go Eagles and then we lost but you know
it might be like a roulette wheel where
you keep betting the wrong [__] until
you actually bet the right [__] you just
got to stick with the color it's that
whole thing of
like quit before they hit a big hey
emotions aside you've been watching
football all year who do you think would
just take it yeah no emotions all stats
don't worry about all this junk mumbo
jumbo I think the Colts would take it if
they're in no I don't think yeah you
should bet against yourself for sure no
no I I don't think that no I think I
think the Chiefs dude you have to he
just [__] figures it out he just
[__] does some Wizardry [__] and like
just wins he just [__] wins he
doesn't you can take stats like from
from how many times you face each other
like where you're at and like you know
you can pick your favorites and your
odds and stuff but some people just like
under the lights under the pressure do
magic dude he evades pressure like
nobody have ever seen before he has a
pocket presence he could just he just
knows when [__] are on his ass
and he like steps ahead just in the nick
of time he's crazy who won last year
what's that who won last year the Chiefs
I won yeah you won last year I could
pick Chiefs again cuz I won yeah but
yeah but I think they're going to win
though I think they're going to win but
then I'm scared cuz I'm like and what if
he doesn't that be so funny that's also
funny that's
also you want to do you want to breach
the rules for once and and let Steve and
Joe pick the cheat that makes that makes
it so much more funnier though that
Steve has been betting against the chief
this whole time and he when he finally
does
flip if they lose they lose that is
really funny that is funny how would you
like to switch it where he's the odd one
out for this Super Bowl I have to ride
with the boys I'll never not ride with
the boys but that's pretty funny though
because you feel so strongly about it
this time it would be hilarious if he
went Chiefs and we went 49ers I think
the funniest I think the funniest part
would be that Nick isn't here to decide
and he's just got to put his [__]
money on whatever all of us ride with
the boys and then Nick has to just be
the other guy that's pretty funny cuz
all of you guys want to vote 49ers no
I'm just saying all of us together Nick
by
himself I don't care I just want to beat
whatever you guys do yeah so Joe's the
odd man out okay so no matter what he
doesn't want to ride with he does want R
we'll put his bet on a really hard to
attain like spread or something
yeah like something super f play
safety we'll take his $100 to put on
first place safety watch she wins it and
it's like a million we just don't tell
them we oh [__] we delete this video yo
that's hella funny so stupid do you guys
know how to play all those odds uh no
I'm just learning about I don't know
anything about that I I just learned
about it like basically in the last two
years and I barely know I all I know how
to do is like go in there and say how do
you bet on the team and then they just
give me the ticket yeah bet like them
how they seeming the national anthem or
some [__] or like how many people are
going to fart in the [__] bet on the
time of the national anthem how long is
it going to be that's what they do it's
crazy it's crazy D the prop bets are
like a book you get a whole book in
Vegas wow yeah it's crazy we should do
that one year nuts I'm down actually
look at the book and go down the L cuz
like it's like you can put like 20 bucks
in and win like hundreds you could do
that on first first um touchdown whoever
predicting who whoever that's going to
be that usually hits pretty hard if you
get it I don't know enough
so who are we who are we betting on I
want to do Chiefs dude I want to do
Chiefs that's what makes me want to do
49 I know oh no so that would make Joe
49ers we're going to all bet on the
Chiefs Joe's going to B on 49ers at the
end of the day that was his original
first respond that's true that's true
that's originally in the text like has
the same name as Joe Montana we can't so
we're going to win more money then if if
we're right okay cool barely though the
spread's not like huge the Chiefs okay
well cuz the 49ers are the favorite ni
only one that has a chance to win real
big 49 is the favorite they they have so
so Nick has to he can't bet on the
actual who wins he just had to bet some
side bet some side bet that wins huge
like the um isn't there like total total
amount of points scored the over yeah
the over under is 47 and A2 47 and A2 so
what do we say what does that even mean
so over if you could bet if do you think
the points are going to be over 47 and
A2 so let's say it's like 21 to 14 is
the final score right then that means
it's only 35 so that's under on 40 right
both team scoring adds up to 47 and2 wow
so you think it's going to go above that
or below 47 and a half is a lot though
is it that's everyone thinks it's going
to be high scoring I feel like Nick
wouldn't care if we both if we put his
money on something that crazy no that's
that's regular that's not crazy that's a
regular bet we got we got to throw him
on something like how many field goals
oh yeah let's do that or like how many
times to cut a ter whip will be a bet I
guarantee it yeah how many times cut we
should do that for Nick that would be
the one that would be the one that's the
one how many times are they going to cut
to
[Music]
taor yeah it could be it could be third
I don't know and make it really high
like the amount that they would cut so
that he's constantly like in the last
second he's like come on Cut tour dude
how about this I tell we we text Nick
and we go hey Nick we need you to pay
right 100 bucks whatever then I text him
6 hours later and I'm like hey Nick
we're going to need you to pay some more
as if I as if we already lost his money
[Laughter]
somehow yeah we gambled his money away
somehow just to [__] with him cuz he's
not here today yeah I don't think he'd
pay it though he be like n knowing Nick
he'd be like what the [__] he still do
yeah he'll probably pay yeah he would he
would but then like what happened to his
money but he'd pay it but he'd ask he's
so trusting he'd be like I don't know
like the guys like they're like yeah do
that they just said I had to do it
again those guys supposed be [__] up
somehow whatever Nick's the over under
on on Taylor slift sightings but the
over over got you got to go for the Hope
got to go for the most dude if he wins
so much money that would be [__]
hilarious we don't tell them yeah split
it we split it we don't tell yeah well
we all split it was our idea we're the
ideas guy yeah why is gambling so
fun because it just enhances
everything like watching the game dude
last two years after betting on the
Super Bowl cuz I'm never going back your
Stakes yeah I have stakes in it and then
when I lost last year I was miserable
the this year just been doing NBA prize
picks all the time where you just like
pick random players to bet the over
under on because you can't do MGM sports
book um in uh in California so legally
we can only do things like prize picks
so then now because I'm like forced to
bet on like random ass [__] players
from different teams I actually watch
like everybody play and I'm like
invested in like the most random [__] if
I'm like at the game it won't just be
like oh did my team score did they not
it'll be like one more [__] assist
come on you know what I mean you're just
betting for the most random stats so
like that kind of [__] just makes you so
invested in this [__] so you're like
cut the Taylor cut the Taylor and you're
like Nick be Nick dude plus ever since I
got into fantasy same thing dude I watch
everything cuz it's like there's stakes
in it all right let's bet on more stuff
why are we not betting on more things
let's go to [__] taica basketball
game and bet on that game dude I'm so
down how many people are going to
us no one's going to pay us if we
there's no money in it that's true oh
yeah that's true all right but why are
all these adults at this
kids screaming in the bleachers and
we're not betting the line either we're
betting the [__] we're taking the
money line we're not do we're not doing
the points we're not taking the points
we're taking the money okay so just we
we want them to win I I know what that
means sometimes when you bet the points
it's so [__] annoying cuz it's like
you know it's like oh it's like the
Packers game right so the the game was
Packers plus 10 so you basically like
you needed them to cover that and they
did so the Packers win plus plus 10 they
have to get within 10 they have to get
within 10 points but if they go over if
they go over that then you lose oh so
it's just a even win or lose that's it
yep okay that's what I want but the but
the payouts smaller huh it's smaller for
sure y so Chiefs and then you're doing
49ers and then Nick is the Taylor Swift
cutaways how much how much how much are
we putting in how much do we have
I I think 100 bucks each bucks yeah okay
unless you guys want to get spicy go
like wa W I'm not doing a th said I'm
not doing a th doing a th I'm not crazy
I only bet playoffs 100 bucks then by
the way I've gambled more than a
thousand but for some reason I'm I'm
getting more reasonable these days
because you keep losing more than a th
well you want to do Sports bet though
you're like into it like you you you
keep on bringing this up to me I know I
I just dream of gambling and I wish I
could do it again but all my money goes
to other things like I like to I'm
probably gambling but it's called
Investments yeah yeah it's definitely
gambling yeah just a different sport so
should we just up it just because we
should just constantly up it I think
it's I think it's funny to up it so it's
200 this time or or like 150 does that
mean next year's 300 or 200 if we're 150
this year n you got to up it by a whole
denomination it's got to be 200 then if
you want to up it but Bart's the kind of
guy that says I have a th000 bucks to
spend on gambling and if I lose it all
I'm happy as [__] what if we just double
it every year so 400 afterwards double
it every year holy sh 1 2 4 holy [__] oh
my God you're crazy I mean it's not
crazy if you want it I mean we're really
also betting that JK is around that
long well lasted pretty long the
Cockroach of YouTube yeah we we'll be
bet
$32,000 on the Super Bowl oh my God
we're pretty uh resilient so 200 is are
we doing 200 or 100 let's do 200 [__] it
let's do 200 let's do 200 that's a nice
even number it hurts enough to lose it
yeah it hurts a lot yeah cuz 100 just
feels like a fancy dinner this 200 bucks
is something really substantial we want
to feel real pain I want I I want to
feel angry when we lose what do we want
to what do we want to feel so much paid
for and then I want I want him to be
able to gloat really well yeah last time
I don't think I went in hard enough cuz
you guys were so sad you won like 600
bucks huh I don't remember he did he did
that's it was like 400 something it was
400 something so if you wins this time
would be almost a th000 if we put in 200
I don't know we got it's something I'm
it's the against the casino if it was
against him personally that's [__]
funny that would be funny Hey Joe we
yeah but that means if you lose you got
to pay us all just take his personal
money that's way funnier
if I lose you guys keep you guys have to
split a 100
bucks that's Su if it's against me you
might as well just buy lunch one day if
you win we're only giving you 20 bucks
no if I win I take all of your money if
I lose you guys take you guys split 200
bucks damn let's do it 200 each and then
uh
$200 Taylor Swift side beds for for yeah
and then whenever the Taylor Swift side
bed is and whenever you if you guys do
win you're like yay and Nick's like yay
we're like no not you You' been on the
Taylor Swift overt no because if he wins
the Taylor Swift side bets I bet you
those odds are even more favorable to go
the over on that well that he'll be by
himself yeah but that's what's funny
about so that means that means whatever
it is that any of us can win Max on that
game itself right that's what Nick can
win anything extra is food it's I just
like that when when we all win and and
then Nick's like he didn't win we're
like what were you thinking 50
what were you thinking you idiot over he
doesn't even know what he been on I'm
going to ask him for $200 and then 4
hours later I'm going be like hey man we
going need
another2 that's my
favorite